caixa veneno dio la primera medalla de
oro a francia la judoca de 28 años ganó
en la categoría de menos 63 kilos en una
final que disputó ante la eslovena tina
30 en regla misma ayudó cante la que se
tuvo que enfrentar en la final en río
2016 y ante la que había perdido en esa
ocasión muchísimas lágrimas momentos de
emoción se vivieron aquí en el nippon
budokan en tokio tras esa victoria
francesa otro que se convirtió en
campeón olímpico esta vez en surf fue el
brasilero ítalo ferreira tras vencer a
la japonesa canoa y garay la medalla de
bronce fue para el australiano override
quien venció a otro de los favoritos
otro brasilero gabriela medina y debo
decirles que la final del surf fue
absolutamente espectacular muy
palpitante debido a las condiciones
climáticas que trajo consigo un tifón
que está atravesando por japón el agua
que también ha traído varias medallas
más a brasil bueno otra más esta mañana
en la final de 200 metros libres fue
fernando scheffer quien se quedó con la
medalla de bronce con un tiempo que
además le permite tener récord
nacional la medalla de oro la medalla de
plata fue para la dupla británica sandy
y don cannes code